so my own Inquisitor is a dalish elf
mage you know he started off being able
to cast this lightning spell but I ended
up going down the cold route for the
most part pretty frequently I would cast
the spell that would I somebody up and
freeze them or sand and slow them down
but I overtime I kind of got used to
this blizzard spell which is a big area
of effect spell that would that would
cause chills for everybody that was
caught in for every enemy that was
caught in that area that was handy
sometimes
but other times it wasn't so handy
because when you use it your your
stamina just keeps going down and down
and down and down and down I chosen
dalish elf and a rogue and I focused on
the archery tree to start from which
basically gives you like a powered up
shot and then I quickly unlocked this
sweet backflip shot that like you
backflip and you do this shotgun blast
it's kind of an evasion thing which was
good because I was starting to get
people up in my face and I needed a way
to get away quickly from them that flips
did the trick there's a few abilities
that you get as a 200 warrior that I
think are uniquely situated to do only
in real time like they just wouldn't
work in the tactical view which is kind
of like heartbreaking because I so love
during there's one in the tactical style
but one of the abilities is you block an
incoming strike which you have to hit
you have to line up the animation
perfectly and you can hold it down but
it just drains your stamina so you kind
of want to get it right but the good
thing is it interrupts any animation
you've started if you do another ability
that has like a long build up and then
you immediately block because an
incoming attacker is about to hit then
you'll activate the ability and then you
do a counter immediately and if you
upgrade it you'll knock them down which
then leads to another attack that you
have that basically just slams the
ground with your sword and does like
massive damage to enemies that are
already knocked down in the early going
the archer actually didn't like end up
being that much about skills so I tried
to pick
it was just kind of like hey I'm back
here I'm shooting I'm at the move so I
wanted to like mix it up I tried to pick
stuff that would allow me to be a little
more strategic like gain bonus damage if
you're elevated so I would always try to
find high ground there was one for that
power shot that you can unlock that
allows it to penetrate targets and do
bigger damage to the subsequent targets
which was really good I'm really
enjoying that one and then I unlocked
this one which is basically like monster
shot you kind of like pull it way back
you aim and it takes few seconds and
then like you blow the first dude up for
a huge amount of damage and knock him on
his ass and it's really fun so I've been
enjoying the archer a bunch more and
another one that is just more ridiculous
but you have to hold down whatever
button you have it it's a whirlwind
attack so I just take my few mungus
weapon and you hold it down the longer
you hold it down you can upgrade it so
it does more damage the longer you do it
so as long as you're not interrupted by
another attack you just like walk around
the battlefield doing circles the damage
is going up and up and up so yeah being
a warrior is actually a lot of fun this
game because of the real-time this it's
interesting in Dragon Age because you
can choose party members based on what
they bring to combat I'm not one of
those people I choose party members
based on who I like like my favorite
characters as opposed to my favorite
combatants because I'm an archer yeah it
basically means that Varrick as soon as
I got an option to have another party
member Varrick stayed home because I'm
like we have this I got this covered
I got snitch my favorite would be me
going along having Casandra there is
more or less a tank bringing along iron
bull as more of a damage dealer he I
always gave him two-handed stuff so that
he could really wallop enemies and that
fourth slot I went back and forth I
would take Varrick sometimes because I
like when Varrick and Casandra interact
Dorian and Vivian there's two majors you
can pick up for your companions I ran
the tables on spirit for Dorian and fire
for Viviana and then having both of them
in a party at the same time is like such
a good compliment
because the spirit is just super
protective of everybody he does like a a
barrier he does a resurrect the gana is
just pure damage with a firewall
fireball explosion area defects so it's
just instead of having a mages that's
balanced having to mages that are just
min maxed that's been a cool thing to do
so when I got Serra a road also I expect
her into the like backstab dagger e1
doing the backstab you can upgrade one
of her stabs so that she executes sit
and then turns invisible and so you can
kind of scoot away approach another guy
hit him with double stab so that was
kind of fun and that party balance ended
up working out pretty well
I feel like combat was at its best when
you were closing some of the tougher
rifts um the combat is typically pretty
easy if you're you know if you're going
out and doing things that are meant to
be and you're you know when you're in
your general level so you go out you can
typically spend your time in third
person and do your stuff and let your
party members do their things
occasionally switching to party members
to either drink a potion or to drop a
bomb or something like that it can be
kind of tricky like if you if you from
the tactical view if you try to like say
revive a fallen character sometimes you
know the AI will take over and they'll
stop doing what you want to do and then
just start doing something else so it
can be a little micromanage e even from
a tactical camera point of view it's not
quite the Holy Trinity in the sense that
you don't really have healers but you do
have buffers so it's it's best to just
you know like let your tank be tanky and
then get everybody else out there to to
deal damage and buff up the party and
goop up the enemy
you